[Música]
economía en directo América de Francia
24 me acompaña en el estudio Daniela
Blandón Dani volvemos nuevamente a
hablar de las noticias económicas del
mundo porque precisamente según la ocde
nuestro planeta podría evitar una
recesión para el año 2022 incluso 2023
sí Raúl pues la organización para la
cooperación el desarrollo económico se
entregó hoy su informe actualizado de
perspectivas económicas que refleja una
posición un poco menos pesimista que la
revelada en septiembre pasado también
conocida como el club de países ricos
esta organización cree que el mundo va a
crecer 3,1% este año que Estados Unidos
concretamente lo harán 1,8% que la zona
Euro lo harán un 3,3% nada despreciable
los tres tímidamente al alza frente a la
revisión anterior sin embargo para el
próximo año si se espera sino una
recesión al menos una fuerte
desaceleración en todos los casos como
vemos en gráfico con Europa como la
región más afectada también se espera
que la inflación siga su trote con muy
pocas excepciones la recomendación final
que hace la ocd es seguir subiendo las
tasas de interés para desincentivar el
consumo y bajar la inflación algo con lo
que el fondo monetario internacional
está muy de acuerdo pero no así el Banco
Mundial el Banco Mundial ha dicho que
esta política lo que hará es acelerar la
recesión Dani y en otras noticias de
España propone alibios hipotecarios para
un millón de hogares en el gobierno de
este país y los bancos alcanzaron un
principio de acuerdo sobre medidas de
este tipo como por ejemplo la ampliación
de las amortizaciones de los préstamos
es decir que se difieran a más tiempo en
especial para familias de clase media el
gobierno les dio un plazo de un mes para
ultimar detalles y firmar el acuerdo
definitivo por su parte también el
gobierno alemán anunció hoy que los
consumidores y las empresas van a
recibir subsidios para suavizar el golpe
de los precios más altos tanto del gas
natural como de la electricidad esto a
partir de enero dos meses antes de lo
que habían planeado originalmente y esto
le va a costar al erario unos 4.500
millones de euros más dos medidas anti
inflacionarias en dos países muy
importantes de Europa cuando se habla de
Whisky y se habla también de un
fabricante de juguetes Pues no hay mucha
cosa en común no pero que los lleva a
algo en común una pelea en los
tribunales Por qué Dani así de Raúl y lo
van a ver ustedes en las imágenes que
vamos a mostrar en unos segundos la
Corte Suprema de Estados Unidos decidió
admitir una apelación de la marca de
licores usted la debe conocer Jack
Daniels para evitar que una compañía que
vende juguetes para perros use diseños
que parodian su Marca Registrada que es
All the number Seven Black Label
Tennessee whisky la historia es la
siguiente el gigante del whisky concede
en Kentucky había entrado en disputada
de marcas con una empresa llamada VIP
por su juguete para mascotas llamado
patt spaniels que ustedes ven en las
imágenes y que imita el diseño de una
botella de Jack Daniels con alteraciones
en el texto relativas a los perros
Entonces ya no dice 100% aprobado sino
100% maloliente Y hay muchos otros
ejemplos dentro de las etiquetas tras la
queja de Jack Daniels su contraparte
pidió amparo en un tribunal federal y en
2020 se dijo que es de juguete era un
trabajo muy creativo que tenía un
mensaje humorístico protegido por la
primera enmienda de libertad de
expresión contemplada en la Constitución
Jack Daniels no estuvo de acuerdo acudió
Entonces de nuevo a la Corte Suprema y
sus colegas con grandes empresas como
Campbell sup Levi Strokes y Patagonia
presentaron escritos que respaldan esta
apelación diciendo que por años les ha
pasado lo mismo aunque esto no va a
garantizar tampoco que le den la razón y
como no conocer a Jack Daniels usted una
vez me regaló una botella para mi
cumpleaños Sí con Juan y Jennifer no me
acuerdo bueno señor pues indicadores
económicos
los mercados están operando la semana a
la baja debido preocupaciones sobre
medidas más estrictas en China para
frenar el avance del Hobbit 19 que
hicieron que el principal índice de la
bolsa de Hong Kong cayera más del 1%,
por segundo día consecutivo Europa opera
ligeramente al alza a pesar de que la
ocd la señaló como la región que se verá
más afectada por la desaceleración
económica el próximo año y que tenemos
como cifra al día ahora estoy cumpliendo
me paga mi deuda 600 dólares que costó
la edición especial del más reciente
libro de Bob Dylan que se llama en
español la filosofía de la canción
moderna y por qué le doy este precio no
es para que lo compre ni mucho menos de
hecho Les recomiendo no comprarlo
Por qué Porque su editorial Simon and
Shooter está ofreciendo reembolsos a
quienes lo adquirieron pensando que el
libro de edición limitada tenía la firma
a mano del cantautor esta empresa
reconoció que los autógrafos no eran
originales a manos sino que eran
réplicas impresas así reaccionaron a las
a las decenas de quejas en redes
sociales de quienes encontraron
sospechosas similitudes en las firmas de
sus libros a pesar de que cada uno venía
con una carta del propio sí oh de Simon
and Shooter avalando la autenticidad de
la firma no Dios mío un engaño porque lo
que vale es el puño inglés
uno lo baja en Google y lo imprime ahí
sale lo pones el libro
Dani como siempre Muchísimas gracias por
toda la información económi